Schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Ujag. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesegespräch durchführen.
Damit sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin einverstanden, Doktor.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Michael Kaiser.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
M-i-i-a-a-i-l
Michael
K-a-i-s-i-r
Kaiser
Okay. Herr Kaiser, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 68 Jahre alt, Doktor.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
24.08.1957
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,83 Meter.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin 85 Kilo schwer.
Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Herr Schmid.
Okay. Danke für die Informationen. Herr Kaiser, was kann ich Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Ja, Doktor. Heute bin ich hier, weil ich vor etwa einer Stunde plötzlich schlecht Luft bekommen habe.
Nachdem ich einen Niesenfall hatte, Doktor.
Herr Kaiser, hatten Sie früher noch einiges zu tun?
Nein, das war mein erstes Beschwerden.
Okay. Haben Sie außer diesem Beschwerden auch eine Brustschmerzen oder ein Engelgefühl in der Brust?
Nein, Brustschmerzen habe ich keine.
Aber mein Herz ist ras, Doktor.
Mein Herz ist ras.
Also, Herz ist rasen, okay.
Okay. Also Sie haben seit einer Stunde Luftnot.
Die Luftnot ist nach einem Niesenfall aufgetreten.
Okay.
Herr Kaiser, ich möchte das Anamnese-Gespräch unterbrechen.
Warum, Doktor?
Ich glaube, das ist eine Notfallsituation.
Was?
Sie haben eine Luftnot-Probleme und das kann für Sie gefährlich sein.
Deswegen möchte ich das Anamnese-Gespräch unterbrechen und möchte ich Ihre Lunge abhören.
Okay?
Okay.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte das Anamnese-Gespräch unterbrechen.
Ich denke, der Patient leidet an einem Pneumothorax.
Der Patient leidet unter plötzlich aufgetretener Luftnot nach einem Niesenanfall.
Deswegen möchte ich die Lungen des Patienten anhören und die Vitalparameter überwachen.
Aber jetzt bin ich in der Prüfung und ich möchte das Anamnese-Gespräch weitermachen.
Darf ich?
Ja.
Danke.
Herr Kaiser, husten Sie?
Ja, Doktor.
Ich habe husten, ja.
Ist der Husten getrocknet oder mit einem Auswurf?
Getrocknet.
Ich habe keinen Auswurf.
Okay.
Herr Kaiser, haben Sie eine Hautfarbeveränderung im Gesicht, besonders am Lippen?
Nein, ich habe keine.
Okay.
Herr Kaiser, haben Sie Ihre Brustregionen verletzt?
Nein, ich habe keine verletzt.
Treten diese Luftnot bei Belastung oder in Ruhe?
Ja.
Ich habe keine Bemerkungen, weil ich etwa eine Stunde diese Schmerzen habe, Doktor.
Okay.
Aber Sie haben dieses Problem, ich meine Luftnot, auch in Ruhe, ja?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Herr Kaiser, haben Sie geschwollene Beine, die sich nicht mehr bewegen?
Nein.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine bemerkt?
Ich habe keine bemerkungen, Doktor.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Ich fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Oder haben Sie sich unterfrost, Nachtschweiß?
Ja, ich schwitze stark.
Auch dann ist es mir schwindlig, Doktor.
Ich habe eine Unruhe und mein Herz rastet, Doktor.
Alles klar.
Ich glaube, Sie leiden unter Kaltschweiß, ja?
Ja.
Okay.
Herr Kaiser, ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, ich fühle mich dabei auch übel, Doktor.
Mussten Sie erbrechen?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht übergeben.
Okay.
Herr Kaiser, darf ich fragen, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist normalerweise gut.
Okay.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ich habe keine Schlafstörungen, Doktor.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklich ab- oder zugenommen?
Ich habe nicht gewonnen, aber ich denke, ich bin gleich gewischt.
Okay, alles klar.
Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Wasserlassen, Stuhlgang?
Ja, ich leide seit etwa fünf bis sechs Jahren an Felsstoppen, Doktor, ja.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich nehme gelegentlich ein Abfürmeter, aber weiß aber den Namen nicht.
Kein Problem.
Also ich werde Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren für diese Details, ja?
Danke schön, Doktor.
Sehr gerne.
Und beim Wasserlassen ist alles ordentlich?
Ja, ja, ich habe keine Probleme mit Wasserlassen, ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Corona-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin gegen alles Wichtige geimpft, Doktor, ja.
Okay.
Herr Kanzler, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, ich habe seit meinem 52.
Leben ja Bluthochdruck, ja.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, nehme regelmäßig ein Abfürmeter, zehn Milligramm morgens und abends, ja.
Sonst?
Ja, außerdem hatte ich 1997 und 2008 zwei Herzinfarkte, Doktor, ja.
Und bei beiden wurde mir Stents eingesetzt.
Seitdem nehme ich täglich Acetylsalicylic Acid, 100 Milligramm.
Wie oft nehmen Sie ein?
Ein morgens.
Okay, alles klar. Sonst? Irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe weitseitige Kniearthrose und schon lange Rückenschmerzen, Doktor.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme? Also ich meine Rückenschmerzen zum Beispiel?
Ja, es war sehr lange. Ungefähr seit 20 Jahren, ja, Doktor.
Und nehmen Sie ein Medikament dagegen ein?
Ja, früher habe ich dagegen ein Morphinpflaster genommen.
Aber wegen der Nebenwirkungen benutze ich seit etwa sechs Jahren alle drei Tage ein Morphinpflaster.
Herr Kaiser, was meinen Sie mit Nebenwirkungen? Also haben Sie eine Allergie gegen den Morphinpflaster, oder?
Ja, ja, ja, Allergie, ja.
Wie aussieht sich diese Allergie?
Meine Haut war rot, und Ausschlag und Juckreis.
Alles klar. Und Sie haben weitseitige Knie-Schmerzen, Kniearthrose.
Kniearthrose, Kniearthrose, ja.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein, darf ich fragen?
Noalkin, Doktor.
Also Sie haben...
Nein, nicht Noalkin. Ich habe Allergie gegen Noalkin.
Ich habe gelegentlich Paraseptamol 500 mg bei Wetter.
Und seit wann leiden Sie unter Knie-Schmerzen?
Seit fünf Jahren.
Seit fünf Jahren, ok. Das war es, oder?
Ja, seit zehn Jahren wurde ich wegen einer Vergiftung bei der Arbeit stationär behandelt.
Was für eine Vergiftung meinen Sie?
Entschuldigung bitte?
Was für eine Vergiftung meinen Sie? Also Nahrungsmittelvergiftung oder?
Nein, nein. Chemisch.
Bei der Arbeit, richtig?
Ja, ja, bei der Arbeit, ja.
Und vor sechs Jahren wurde ich am Karpaltunnelsyndrom operiert, Doktor.
Welche Seite?
Rechte Seite.
Ok. Und sonst? Irgendwelche andere Voroperationen haben Sie, oder?
Ja, außerdem wurde ich vor etwa zehn Jahren wegen einer Zisteste in der Liken Lunge operiert, ja.
Eine Ziste, ja.
Eine Zisteste in der Linken Lunge operiert, ja.
Ok. Herr Kanzler, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf außer genannten Medikamenten ein?
Ich nehme keine anderen Medikamente ein.
Alles klar. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Allergie gegen Novalgie haben.
Ja.
Sonst haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Allergien?
Ja, ich habe auch Hundtierallergie.
Hundhaare meinen Sie?
Ja, ja, Hundhaare, ja.
Wie ersetzt sich diese Allergie?
Rückreiß und Ausschlag.
Ok. Herr Kanzler, rauchen Sie?
Ja, Doktor, leider rauche ich ja.
Seit wann und wie viel rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche seit 30 Jahren halb Schachter Zigarette täglich.
Ok. Herr Kanzler, wenn Sie möchten, können wir Sie dabei unterstützen?
Ich meine, wir haben ein gutes Programm im Krankenhaus mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören, ja?
Ja, ich möchte natürlich, Doktor.
Ja, gerne. Wir können darüber nach dem Anamnesgespräch widersprechen, ja?
Ok, danke.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ich trinke gelegentlich am Wochenende oder traf meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen oder eine Verein ein Glas Wein.
Ok. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich nehme keine Drogen, Doktor.
Ok, das freut mich.
Herr Kanzler, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall oder Brüthochtruck?
Mein Vater ist mit 66 Jahren alt an Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Meine Mutter ist 70 Jahre alt an Brustkrebs gestorben, Doktor.
Mein Beileid, Herr Kaiser.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Ok, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich wohne alleine. Meine Frau ist vor zehn Jahren an Brustkrebs gestorben, Doktor.
Mein Beileid, Herr Kanzler.
Ok, haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder, zwei Sohne.
Sind die Sohne gesund?
Ja, alles ist gesund.
Herr Kanzler, ich glaube Sie sind jetzt Rentner, oder?
Ja.
Und früher, was haben Sie als Beruflich gemacht?
Ich habe Ingenieur gearbeitet.
In einer Fabrik?
Ja, in einer chemischen Fabrik.
Ok. Herr Kaiser, das waren meine Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja Doktor, ich habe schlecht Luft bekommen. Was habe ich?
Herr Kaiser, Sie haben Luftnot, weil Sie ein Problem mit den Lungen haben.
Also ich meine, normalerweise gibt es keine Luft zwischen Brustkorb und Lungen.
Aber wegen dieser Niesenfälle hatten Sie ein Problem und deswegen leiden Sie unter Luftnot.
Sie haben früher eine Sistoperation in der linken Lunge.
Diese Situation kann dieses Problem verursachen. Deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen die weiteren Informationen mitteilen.
Ok.
Doktor, ich habe eine Frage.
Ja gerne.
Ich muss im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Herr Kaiser, ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben.
Wenn wir etwas auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Wie lange dauert diese Prozedur?
Wie gesagt, Sie sollen ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Wir werden Sie hier im Krankenhaus beobachten, ob Ihre Beschwerden weg sind.
Dann können wir Sie wieder entlassen. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Danke Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Danke schön. Herr Michael Kaiser ist 68 Jahre alt, 1,83 Meter groß und 85 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Kaiser, ich dachte sich heute bei uns wegen seit einer Stunde bestehender Duis bleu vor,
dem Patienten zufolge seien die Beschwerden nach einem Niesenanfall aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Der Patient berichtete über Trakikardie, innere Unruhe, vertigo, kaltes Schweiß und Nausee ohne Emesis.
Die Fragen nach eigener Pektoris, ein Gefühl in der Brustregion, in der Brust, Cyanose,
Beinödeme, Verletzung, Fieber wurden verneint.
Ich habe das Anamnesigespräch unterbrochen, weil ich eine Pneumonie bei den Patienten dachte.
Ich habe die Vitaprimeter bei den Patienten überwacht und sofort habe ich eine Torakadranage durchgeführt.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist bis chronische Observation seit 5 bis 6 Jahren unauffällig.
Der Patient nehme dagegen ein Abführmittel bei Bedarf ein.
Der Name von Medikament sollte geklärt werden.
Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Corona-Infektionen geimpft.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit 52 Jahren lebensjahr bestehende arterielle Hypertonie.
Seit 5 Jahren bestehende koksartroge beidseitige Gonarthrose.
Seit 20 Jahren bestehende chronische Lumbaralgie.
Er hat zweimal Myokatinfarkt in 1997 und 2008.
Er sei wegen einer KHK-PTCA durchgeführt und ein Stent eingesetzt worden.
Der Patient nehme Ende April 10 mg morgens und abends,
100 mg morgens, 500 mg bei Bedarf ein.
Der Patient benutze seit 6 Jahren alle 3 Tage Morphin-Filaster.
Früher habe er Novalgin-Tabletten eingenommen, aber er habe eine Allergie gegen Novalgin.
Deswegen nehme er Novalgin-Tabletten nicht mehr ein.
Vor 10 Jahren hatte er eine Vergiftung gegen chemische Stoffe bei der Arbeit,
die stationär behandelt worden sei.
Vor 6 Jahren sei er wegen einer Carpaltonal-Syndrom operiert worden.
Vor 10 Jahren sei er wegen einer Cyst in der linken Lunge operiert worden.
Er hat Allergie gegen Novalgin, die sich durch Exanthem und Puri-Tis äußert.
Er hat auch Hundehaareallergien, die sich durch Puri-Tis und Exanthem äußert.
Er ist Raucher, er rauchte seit 30 Jahren 10 Zigaretten täglich, das entspricht 15 Pakiers.
Er trinke ein Glas Wein am Wochenende und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater mit 66 Jahren an Myokadinfarkt verstorben sei
und die Mutter sei mit 70 Jahren an Mammakarzinom verstorben.
Er sei Einzelkind verwitwet. Vor 10 Jahren sei seine Frau an Magenkarzinom verstorben.
Er habe zwei Kinder, zwei Söhne, die gesund seien und er wohne alleine.
Er sei Rentner, früher habe er als Ingenieur in einer chemischen Fabrik gearbeitet.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Pneumothorax aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter flüssig aufgetretener Dyspneu nach einem Niesenanfall.
Katschweiß, innere Unruhe, vertigo, Übelkeit, also diese Symptome sprechen für einen Pneumothorax.
Als die Phasendiagnosen kommen Myokadinfarkt, Pulmonar Lungenembolie in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich bei den Patienten zunächst die Vitalparameter überwachen
und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen. Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf,
ob Pneumose, Venenstauung am Hals, asymmetrische Thoracal Expansion
und verminderte Atemgeräusche an betreffenden Lungen vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose sich zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbilds, CAP, BSG, Blutgasanalyse, Dedumere, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte,
Gerinnungsparameter, Elektrolyten, Herzinsime bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Röntgen des Thorax durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien genau zu beurteilen.
Danach würde ich eine Zete des Thorax durchführen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Wenn meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigt würde, würde ich sofort eine Thorax-Diagnose durchführen.
Ich würde auch ein LKG schreiben, um die Möglichkeit der Herzkrankheit, einen Myokatinfakt auszuschließen.
Ich würde den Patienten einen venösen Zugang legen und würde eine pneumonologische Skonsil anfordern,
um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vergehenweise verstanden sind, werde ich die geplanten Untersuchungen fortfahren.
Herr Oberarzt.
Herr Kollegen, können Sie uns die Zete des Thorax aufklären?
Ja, ich werde gerne Sie über Zete des Thorax aufklären.
Zete des Thorax gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Verletzungen, Entzündungen, Blutungen, Tumore oder andere Veränderungen genau zu erkennen.
Diese Untersuchung benötigt nur noch eine geringe Strahlenbelastung und ist völlig schmerzfrei.
Der Patient soll etwa 30 Minuten ruhig in einer Zeteröhre liegen.
Wenn der Patient eine Platzangst hat, können wir dem Patienten eine Beruhigungsmittel geben.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 20 bis 30 Minuten.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen und einige Kontraindikationen, wie z.B. Schwangerschaft oder Kontrastmittelallergie.
Manchmal sollen wir Kontrastmittel geben, um die Organe sichtbar zu machen.
Es gibt keine Anstrengungen nach der Untersuchung und der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Ja, gerne.
Thoraxdrainage ist die Drainage von Luft oder Flüssigkeit oder Blut aus dem Chlorespalt.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, um den Pneumothorax oder Hemothorax zu behandeln.
Bei dieser Untersuchung desinfizieren wir die Stelle und wir führen eine Nadel in der Chlorespalt ein.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten bei dieser Untersuchung.
Vor dem Eingriff geben wir den Patienten örtliche Betäubung.
Ja, wir geben eine lokale Betäubung vor der Untersuchung.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten bei dieser Untersuchung.
Monaldi und Blaue Methode.
Die Monaldi Methode machen wir in der mittleren Linie und in der zweiten interkostal Region.
Oder die Blaue Methode in der mittleren Linie zwischen vierter und fünfter Rippen.
Wir führen die Nadel in den Chlorespalt ein und wir saugen den Luft oder den Blut ab.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. einige Minuten.
Nach der Untersuchung soll der Patient im Krankenhaus zur Beobachtung bleiben.
Es gibt keine Kontradikationen oder Komplikationen bei der Untersuchung.
Herr Kallögen, in diesem Fall geben Sie den Patienten Sauerstoff?
Auf jeden Fall. Wir sollen sofort den Patienten Sauerstoff geben.
Wir sollen zuerst die Sauerstoffsättigung messen.
Wenn die Sauerstoffsättigung unter 93% ist, sollen wir den Patienten Sauerstoff geben.
Was macht Pneumothorax den Patienten, wenn Sie keine Thorax-Trainage legen?
Das kann lebensbedrohlich sein.
Spannungspneumothorax können wir feststellen.
Diese Situation ist eine lebensbedrohliche Situation.
Wie können wir Spannungspneumothorax diagnostizieren?
Wir sollen die Vitaparameter überwachen.
Wir können bei den Patienten Hypotonie, Tachikalie, Venen, Stauung am Hals bei der Inspektion feststellen.
Und Hypoxie.
Was machen Sie, wenn der Patient Spannungspneumothorax hat?
Wir sollen sofort die Thorax-Trainage durchführen.
Und wir sollen den Patienten in der Intensivstation beobachten.
Während der Intensivstation, was führen Sie den Patienten?
Ich meine, wenn es mit Ventilator-Tag gibt?
Wir sollen die Blutgasanalyse regelmäßig kontrollieren.
Wenn der Sauerstoffsättigung sehr niedrig ist, können wir den Patienten ein Ventilator anschließen.
Und geben Sie während der Therapie Analgetikum den Patienten?
Normalerweise kann der Patient unter atmenbedingter Schmerzen leiden.
Wenn es eine Schmerzen beim Atmen gibt, können wir einen Schmerzmittel geben.
Das ist sehr wichtig für normale Atmung.
Empfehlen Sie in diesem Fall den Patienten eine Operation?
Wenn Sie Ja sagen, welche Operation empfehlen Sie?
Der Patient hatte eine Operation vor zehn Jahren wegen einer Zucht in der linken Lunge.
Wenn es eine resistive Zucht in der linken Lunge gibt, können wir eine Systektomie bei den Patienten durchführen.
Oder wenn der Patient viele Züchte hat, was empfehlen Sie?
Eine Systektomie bei den Patienten?
Nein, eine plurale Adhesion.
Während der Operation führen wir die parietal Pleura entfernen.
Das ist ein guter Satz.
Wenn Sie auf die Plurale adhessen, können Sie die Operation in zehn Minuten beenden.
Wenn Sie es ein bisschen langsamer machen, können Sie es in zehn Minuten beenden.
Wenn Sie es etwas langsamer machen, können Sie es in zehn Minuten beenden.
Das ist normal.
Vielleicht können Sie die finanzielle Anlage noch ein bisschen mehr zwingen.
Bei der Körperlosenversuchung höre ich die Lungen des Patienten ab.
Und welche Teile weniger Lungen geräuchte höre ich.
Das kann man so sagen.
Mit den einfachen und kurzen Sagen, die man kennt, kann man andere Dinge dazugeben.
Mit den Füßen wird die Kante geschlossen und dann wird die Drainage ausgerichtet.
Sie wird nur mit der Füße geschlossen.
Danach wird die Kante mit der Dissektion aufgeführt.
Wenn Sie mit der Füße direkt mit der Drainage gehen, wissen Sie nicht wo Sie hinkehren.
Daher gar nicht mehr die ganze Zeit mit der Dissektion.
Wenn du den Finger nahe hast, nimmst du ihn mit deinem Finger und wenn du ihn nimmst, dann geht es in die andere Seite.
Du nimmst nur den Finger unter die Cilt und dann geht es in die Künfte.
Es gibt keine Art, den Finger direkt in die Cilt zu nehmen.
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Du nimmst schon in die Cilt.
Ja, in die Cilt.
Du nimmst ihn mit den Finger in die Künfte, um nicht zu verletzen, dass du in der Künfte in der Cilt wirst.
Die Künfte ist nicht sehr weit.
Du hast sie in ein paar Wochen direkt zu dir.
Was hast du auch gefragt?
Spannungs?
Tansium Pneumatorex.
Ich wusste das nicht.
Ich wusste es nicht.
Okay.
Denn die Herz und Mediastanstöße werden auf die Gegend geschlossen.
Sie werden in einer Seriöse aufgeteilt.
Deswegen.
Okay.
In der Inspektion gibt es eine unverdankliche Expansion.
Wir hören keine Stimme auf der einen Seite.
Wir bekommen eine Perkussion.
Du hast eine große Höhe.
Du hast die Stimme.
Aber du musst den Schlafschluss schnell machen.
Du musst den Schlafschluss auf den Röntgen schlagen.
Wir hatten eine Tennis-Situation.
Die Rippen-Kontition.
Du musst den Schlafschluss auf den Röntgen-Destorax schlagen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das hier sagt.
Ich muss etwas sagen wie Betkoff Röntgen-Destorax.
Hier ist etwas in den Noten.
Für diese Begriffe.
Röntgen-Geräte.
Schienen und Röntgen-Destorax.
Du kannst das so sagen.
In den Noten steht, dass du direkt auf den Röntgen-Destorax-Training losgehalten hast.
Sie haben den Röntgen nicht beantwortet.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das hier geht.
Man möchte heute auch eine Begegnung geben.
Du hast das schon gemacht.
Aber du hast es schon gemacht.
Vielleicht hat der Mann nichts gemacht.
Du bist der Grund.